what's with the jeans you know a lot of
times advertisers have asked they go how
do you feel about a pre produced
advertisement in other words we just
give you a file and you play it and my
feeling has always been no I think I
think speaking directly to the audience
with products that we actually some you
know use and endorse always works better
there's more of a connection but there's
this one ad that came in where it was
pitched to us and I said you know what I
think it'll still work for our audience
even though it's not us reading the copy
it's made and then we play it okay and
so it's the first time I'm playing it
here on the show and you know obviously
if you guys don't like it you know I'll
tell them and we'll read the copy but I
just thought let's give it a whirl so
here's our mid-show ad you love
delicious homemade desserts but recipes
can be complicated and takes so long to
make hi Kathy Mitchell here with my new
dunk cake cookbook forget measuring now
you can easily make homemade desserts in
minutes it's as simple as dump and bake
for delicious desserts every time
guaranteed watch this start with fruit
that's on your favorite cake mix and
finish with a can of soda or you can use
diet for a guilt-free dessert then just
bake it in the oven for a delicious razz
impeach bump cake
so scrumptious look your kids will
devour this some more chocolate cake in
a skillet and easy here's the cake mix
just step on the good stuff chocolate
chips marshmallows even chocolate
cookies bacon voila the best dessert
ever now here's one of my favorites just
dump syrup sugar cinnamon and nuts in a
pan and then just layer in some biscuits
for fresh warm sticky buns just like
grandma used to make there you go
I love this do you know the there the
books are everywhere now okay they're
like at the pharmacy and stuff yeah I
love it
well I think we got the verdict this is
an ad we can play on the show I think
you'll like it I like it I mean
hopefully the audience likes it I feel
good about it
what a great product yeah clever
marketing yeah
clever branding clever clever clever
dung cake dumb cake yummy pineapple
upside-down cake